la délivrance de passeports
diplomatiques et automatique différent
cependant de passeport diplomatique est
automatique pour l'ensemble des
personnels qui peuvent être amenés à se
déplacer avec le président de la
république et donc sont des passeports
diplomatiques sont délivrées pour une
durée d'un an de mémoire et qui sont
renouvelées de manière automatique par
ministère des affaires étrangères dès
lors qu'ils arrivent à échéance
ça ne confère aucun avantage
on n'avait aucune immunité c'est juste
dès lors que vous vous déplacez avec le
président de la république sur un
déplacement à l'étranger ou ou dans le
cadre de vos missions en précurseur qui
indiquent un peu la nature de vos
fonctions et tout le monde en dispose je
crois même que certaines personnes qui
appartiennent à l'intendance ou aux
cuisines en dispose c'est simplement non
pas une facilité mais c'est celle usage
donc ça confère aucune immunité c'est
pas un passe-droit s'est attribué de
manière automatique sur l'a1 certain
nombre de personnes qui peuvent en
disposer avant le service du protocole
et l'ensemble du personnel de la
chefferie de cabinet est d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des véhicules administratifs
que ce soit dans les préfectures
que ce soit dans les ministères il ya
des attachés de presse de secrétariat
d'état qui dispose de véhicules de
fonction avec gyrophare y a rien de
choquant là dedans
simplement c'est un moyen d'accords jeu
mais je le précise parce que j'ai
compris quand je croise des gens qui
sont choqués par sa simplement c'est
dans le but que vous puissiez remplir
vos missions au mieux et que vous
puissiez vous rendre dans les délais
impartis sur un événement ou que vous
puissiez intégré le cortège du président
la république en toute sécurité
mais c'est pas moi qui fait le choix
d'équiper ce véhicule tous les véhicules
la présidence de la république sont
équipés comme les véhicules des
présidents de commission au sénat du
président de l'assemblée nationale et
ses associés c'est un usage qui n'est
pas si facile est régi par des textes ou
pas mais en tout cas moi je bénéficier
d'aucun avantage à ce moment il fallait
juste si demain on m'avait dit qu'il
fallait se déplacer en vélo j'aurais
pris un vélo